Welcome back everyone it's Charlie cinemacon is
going on right now they just released a Kraven
the hunter trailer for people at the convention
so we'll break it all down they didn't post the
footage online so I have to be kind of careful
about the way I do this video but the footage
also explains how it connects with the larger
Spider-Man movies everyone going crazy about
how good it looks so odds are this will not be
morbidden time again thankfully it seems like
this movie is actually going to be pretty decent
Marvel's first R movie that they've done since
the last Deadpool movie technically Deadpool 3
will be like their next big R movie if you're
brand new to the channel be sure to subscribe to
get all the videos there were a bunch of other
trailers at cinemacon that were just released
for everything so I'll try to make videos for
everything as quickly as possible this week
if you forgot there is a Crave in the hunter
movie being released later this year it's part
of the Sinister Six crossover story that Sony
and Marvel have going on in the background with
the Venom movies a bunch of the other live-action
Spider-Man spin-offs we make all the morbius
it's morbin time jokes but like they set up
Sinister Six in that post-credits scene with the
version of the vulture from the MCU so we know
that they're gonna do a Sinister Six movie I've
already done a bunch of videos about that a lot
of the Multiverse stuff that's going on in those
movies right now too is tied to what's happening
with them building up to Avengers 5 King Dynasty
and Avengers 6 Secret Wars because for instance
Spider-Man across the spider-verse big Multiverse
movie spider-verse movie with a bunch of different
characters from different universes that movie
is also building up to Avengers Secret Wars we're
gonna see the spider-verse characters in live
action versions of themselves during Secret Wars
so all the Multiverse stuff is finally starting to
make sense Kraven is supposed to be part of that
but this first Kraven movie is still meant to be
relatively earth-based within the Venom Universe
it takes place in Venom's Universe Aaron Taylor
Johnson is playing Kraven bet you didn't see that
coming that's right we have another character from
the Multiverse playing different characters in
different Marvel movies that's starting to happen
more and more like there's just so many Marvel
movies coming from Sony from Marvel in the MCU all
the different places eventually you're going to
start to see some characters playing completely
different characters in some Legacy characters
like Andrew Garfield Spider-Man Toby Maguire
Spider-Man coming back Hugh Jackman Wolverine also
a good example that the Kraven the hunter teaser
trailer began with a couple short scenes of Kraven
taking out this military Convoy of villains in a
very bloody fashion remember the movie's supposed
to be R so supposed to be pretty bloody he bites
one dude's nose off he kills another with a large
hunting Spirit like Kraven's trademark spear from
the comics another one gets his face caught in
one of Kraven's very medieval looking hunting
trap devices mangling him super bad then they
started to tie things to the larger Spider-Man
spider verse there was a scene of Kraven versus
the Rhino so the Rhino is meant to be one of
the major Spider-Man villains like one of the
core original Spider-Man villains in the movie
Alessandro navola is playing the character and
because the movie is R it'll be a much darker
hardcore version of the character most people
when they think of the Rhino they think Apollo
giamatti's more comedic version of the rhino
the Kraven teaser trailer footage also made
it clear that this version of the Rhino won't
be like Paul giamatti's Rhino he won't wear
an actual suit like it won't be a mechanical
version of the character it'll actually
be a biological version a little bit more
comic book accurate the way the actor talked
about his character he said that he'll start
out as a normal human and take a serum that
will transform his body so something similar
to what you saw in The Incredible Hulk movie
with the abomination's transformation in that
movie he'd been given the super soldier serum
which had already given him a certain level of
power like Captain America level Powers then the
leader recreated the accident that gave the hook
his gamma powers and some of the Hulk's blood
which is why he turned into that monstrosity
looking version otherwise he would have looked
a little bit more like the Hulk he'll become
way bigger like you would expect the Rhino to be
from the comics the full tagline for the movie
that was in the trailer read no one survives
the hunt Russell Crowe is playing Kraven's
father from the comics the previous craving the
hunter who passes the mantle down to his son
he also had a pretty crazy relationship with
his father too like it was not a buddy buddy
relationship I believe we're also supposed to
see a version of the chameleon in the movie
because he's also Kraven's illegitimate brother
the full official trailer will release online
around Spider-Man across the spider-verse when
that comes in June big reminder that the movie
is also coming out later this year too they've
been pretty quiet about it lately but based on
all the cinemacon footage in the trailer it sounds
like it's actually going to be pretty decent after
the morbius movie bet you did not see that coming
there have been a bunch of versions of Kraven's
origin story most people remember him from
Spider-Man the Animated Series in the 90s they did
kind of a speed run version of his origin during
that that's a little bit different from the comics
where
Kraven is who I am I belong among the animals
originally in the comics he was born to Russian
aristocrats the Kravenoff family his father
was abusive and it was forced to flee Russia
after the Bolshevik Revolution to the UK later to
the United States eventually his father dies his
mother goes insane is committed to an asylum
which is Infested by spiders and it haunts
Kraven's memory for the rest of his life so it
kind of informs his hatred of Spider-Man although
technically that isn't the reason why he wants
to kill Spider-Man it just sort of establishes
the idea that he does not like spiders in general
so when he comes upon Spider-Man the whole idea
the concept of the character he doesn't like
him that much Kraven becomes a champion Hunter
by adulthood and spends a lot of time hunting big
game in Africa he gains his extra powers like he
actually does have some biological powers from a
special potion that he steals from a witch doctor
the level of powers that they give him are kind
of like super soldier-like abilities like he's
the Captain America level strength putting him
close to Spider-Man's level of strength he has
enhanced strength speed senses decelerated aging
all the things that you would want to have as a
hunter Spider-Man is meant to be a little bit
stronger than Captain America also some of his
powers give him some slightly different abilities
like he's way more bendy than Captain America as
well too but they're meant to be pretty close
look at both Captain America and Spider-Man
didn't hold back they could go toe-to-toe with
each other but ultimately Spider-Man would win
eventually Kraven learns about Spider-Man's
existence in the senses that he will be his
greatest Challenge and he just tries to catch
Spider-Man and kill him for the challenge of it
so it's not like Spider-Man accidentally killed
his parents or anything like that or did anything
terrible to him it's just that he's constantly
seeking out greater challenges to prove himself
the greatest hunter in existence he eventually
does wind up pulling that off during Kraven's
last Hunt storyline probably one of Kraven's
best stories of all time I don't think they're
going straight to that story in the first Kraven
movie but I think they'll try to work up to that
if they do Kraven sequels there might be some
Easter eggs for that in the first Kraven movie
they've been kind of cagey about which version
of Spider-Man exists in Venom's Earth because
vulture mentioned him in the morbius movie
in morbius takes place on Venom's Earth I
know there's tons of questions about the
designation of all the different Earths
because in the Spider-Man across the spider-verse
trailer Miguel O'Hara specifically mentions MCU
Spider-Man and Doctor Strange during the
events of Spider-Man no way home messing
up the Multiverse but get me started on Doctor
Strange and a little nerd back on Earth 1999-99
foreign
and what they're doing with the spider force or
the spider Society is they're calling it trying to
fix all the tears and the errors in the Multiverse
caused by what MCU Spider-Man and Doctor Strange
did but as you heard he calls it Earth 19999
which was the original designation during Marvel
phase one era when agents of shield and all the
other Marvel TV shows were happening that were
kind of separate from the MCU movies a little bit
there was always a question about the continuity
what was connected what was not connected then
eventually Kevin feige had them say that the MCU
Earth was 616 in the Marvel movies then you have
the Spider-Man across the spider-verse trailer so
I know there's lots of questions like who is
correct are they correct in the spider-verse
trainer are they correct in the MCU movies the way
the spider-verse directors talked about it they
said that each character who's talking about
it thinks from their perspective that things
are right so they think of the MCU within the
spider-verse movies on this particular Earth where
they are as Earth 19999 but if you travel to the
MCU and you talk to those characters who actually
know about the Multiverse they would call their
Earth 616 so it's one of those phenomena where
you have characters from different universes using
different designations for their own Universe like
they haven't developed an actual common language
for that yet like they don't all use the same
destination for every single Earth you also
might remember that they featured a comic book
accurate Rhino during Spider-Man no way home it's
meant to be the Rhino from this movie when the
Multiverse starts to tear open more and more of
the Spider-Man villains from the Multiverse start
to come through the Rhino was featured here comic
book accurate Rhino now it's meant to be the Rhino
from The Kraven movie they had a ton of comic
accurate versions of other Spider-Man characters
and villains in this scene so Kraven the hunter
was also one of them with his spear now it's
meant to be the Aaron Taylor-Johnson version in
this movie so it's kind of like they were teasing
all these upcoming movies with these villains that
showed up which I think a lot of us assumed at the
time like are they teasing that these characters
are going to start showing up eventually there's
a version of doppelganger who's the six arm evil
Spider-Man a lot of people thought that that could
be superior Spider-Man 2 so you could pick either
one superior Spider-Man or doppelganger just one
of the six are versions of Spider-Man there was
a comic accurate scorpion not the MCU version who
was more of a mechanical scorpion I think this was
supposed to be black cat who was also supposed to
appear in another live-action spin-off movie at
some point this is another version of Mysterio
from a different Universe not the MCU version
and I think this is meant to be a comic accurate
version of Madame Webb setting up the Madame Web
movie with Dakota Johnson that they just finished
filming a while ago it is supposed to be kind
of like Terminator in the Spider-Man universe
with Spider-Man characters like a character comes
from the future to try and erase Spider-Man from
the past I don't know if this is meant to be a
completely new version of Spider-Man somewhere
from Another Universe or Andrew Garfield's
Spider-Man from his timeline or Toby Maguire's
Spider-Man from his timeline and they didn't say
much about Spider-Man 4 but they did confirm that
Kevin feige in the Marvel people are actually
working on it right now they know what the story
is going to be the planned release date right now
is summer 2025 so they won't start filming for a
little while but they did confirm that Daredevil
and Kingpin will be big parts of the movie
the Marvel people said what's happening
during Daredevil born again will heavily
influence the plot of Spider-Man 4 what happened
with Kingpin becoming mayor of New York City so
we might actually get Spider-Man and Daredevil
teaming up against Kingpin during Spider-Man 4
but there will be other plot happening during the
movie like it isn't just about what's happening
with Kingpin and Daredevil like there'll be other
Spider-Man villains in the movie but generally
it'll be more of a classic Spider-Man type of
story like he's got a classic version of the
suit now it's much more Lo-Fi way more friendly
neighborhood Spider-Man than say like the Iron Man
Stark Tech version of Spider-Man I'll do more
Spider-Man 4 videos when we get more details
about the movie and more Kraven trailer videos
when they start releasing more footage but if
you have any questions about what's happening
with all the movies just write them Below in
the comments everyone click here for that brand
new Flash trailer video with a whole bunch more
Batman and click here for that Spider-Man across
the spider-verse trail that they just released
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!